And that's why I believe they killed
Charlie Kirk. Masad and Israel took him
out. I've
>> been to Israel many times. The whole
country is a fortress. I find this very
hard to believe. I've been to that Gaza
border. You cannot go 10 ft without
running into a 19-year-old with an AR-15
or an automatic machine gun that is an
IDF soldier. Right. The whole country is
surveiled. The last nine months, Israel
was on the brink of civil war. It's not
an exaggeration. This judicial stuff,
there were there were hundreds of
thousands of Israelis taking to the
streets because BB Netanyahu is
basically redefining the Israeli
constitution. There were protests
planned this week against Netanyahu
where they anticipated tens of thousands
of people to take to the streets. That's
all gone, Patrick. The whole country is
the IDF.
>> The whole country is and you're trying
to tell me that they're going to
concerts and kabutzas and schools and by
report.
>> That there is another video that cost
him his life. That there, guys, look,
you cannot make this up. Here we go.
I'll give you one more video. One more
video. Check this out, guys.
Dear brothers and sisters, as we watch
what is unfolding today in we have to
understand that opposition is counting
on us to lose attention, to become
fatigued, and to move on with the new
cycle. And just as we can't allow them
to dictate our attention, we also can't
allow them to dictate the pace of our
solidarity. And part of that solidarity
is going to be there to rebuild Gaza
short-term, long term. I am proud to
give my support, my word of support to
trusted brothers and sisters in the
United Kingdom that have started awak
that have started an endowment to make
sure inshallah that we're there for the
long run. It's going to be long term and
we will not forget our cause inst. We
will not forget the cause of and we will
not forget our brothers and sisters in
welcome to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well in so
this was a I didn't I don't really know
much about this guy Charlie Kirk. I'll
be honest with you. Um, I didn't really
know about his insults to the prophet
wasallam and you know heard some stuff
about the whole god situation but I
didn't know you know it was that level
just regardless I'm not doing this video
because of the other video I've done
because I stand by that because Allah
teaches us in the Quran that these these
people these people sadly he's I believe
him to be an evil person. Yes. And even
though I believe him to be an evil
person I would not wish anyone to harm
anybody like this in any worship. I've
made that clear in my video. Yes. I
venomly disagree with him. But in this
video, bro says, we're going to dissect
who actually killed him. Because if we
look at the videos, I didn't actually
know that I thought this guy was a dieh
hard Zionist, which he was, but he was
actually changing his mind slowly. Now,
before we filmed the brother Zak, he
asked a good question. He said, "Why are
they why would they not kill Candy or um
Tucker Carlson, but they go for uh this
guy?" I said because this guy was die
hard. Imagine if I have a diehard
friend. If he starts doubting me,
everyone's going to be like, "Yo,
there's some other guys that knew of
Ali, but him like him." Who was hold
he's now saying there's a question mark
on Ali like whoa that that's saying
something. That's the reason why they
got rid of him. Here's evidences,
footages. Not only that, brothers and
sisters, which we're going to dissect
many videos on PBD podcast, other
podcasts where he was slowly but surely,
even with the interview with the Ben
Shapiro starting to say question things,
ask some things where he was like, "Hold
on a second." And Benjamin Netany and
Mosad knows they know very well him
someone such a close ally die hard
person who's a Zionist. Yes. Okay.
Christian Zionist. If he comes out
full-blown, it is better he's dead than
him changing massive public opinion
across America. They know the dangers
and I believe they took them out. Here's
the evidences. Let's watch for ourself
step by step. Okay. So, firstly before
that, this is what Charlie Kirk said.
Islam is the sword of the left is using
to slit the throat of America.
The irony. The irony. Now
Charlie Kirk turns to anti-Semitic
stereotypes amid Israel Hamas war. So
you can see clearly that now the people
the Zionists were seen over them saying
this is getting dangerous this is this
our boy this our guy and he's getting
dangerous. Another comment as you can
see here for example this is something
from an individual called Jack Hinkle.
He said he used to be an Israeli
loyalist. He feared Israel would kill
him. He started mildly criticizing
Israel. He said Epstein Epstein was
Mossad, which is true. He led anti-Zion
Zionist speak at his event, which he's
going to mention in a video. We're going
to see Zionist media starts attacking
him. Someone shoots his juggler vein 200
yards away. Netanyahu tweets within
minutes. And we're going to look at
that. The same tweet at the same time
with Donald Trump together.
Paty gets arrested and acts guilty.
Assassin escapes without a trace.
Netanya tweets longer message. Something
tells me they are not going to tell us
the truth about who killed Charlie. Yes,
perfect. Okay, now this is the evidence.
Donald Trump and Netanyahu, just bear in
mind, guys, this is a day before 9/11.
Very bizarrely, they tweet at the same
exact time, exact time, praying for
Charlie Kirk. We must all pray for
Charlie Kirk.
Now, Donald Trump, you can see he's
clear-cut Zionist. You don't see him
speaking against in any way, shape or
form, which shows what anyone that close
to the Zionist entity dares to doubt or
question them. They don't care about
these people who are just, you know,
they changed their mind except look
Candace Owens and no, someone as die
hard as him. Now, watch this video,
guys. We're going to watch this
inshallah step by step. This was
something that was predicted by this
man. I want to show you this in before
we get to the video. This guy is called
Tommy Borum. I don't know who he is. He
said they would if Charlie turned heel
on Israel, they would have someone shoot
him at an open air event and they have
some idiot
with a genetically anomalous issue there
to be a psy guy. I think what what that
means is somebody that you know uh gets
the attention uh somewhere else. Part of
why you never make the deal with the
devil in the first place. These people
know look you need to know some deep
stuff. Now, let's get to the videos.
Here is the first video, guys, of
Charlie Kerb turning slowly against
Israel. Slowly, subtly. They did not
tolerate that. I hope you guys enjoyed
the video, guys. But before that, please
download the Salah Pro app. Brothers and
sisters, we are a charity. All of our
services on the app is for free. Free
kiblinder, no ads, free salah reminders,
encourages to pray, tells you salah
times. You can book a salah instructor,
a Quran instructor. You can order a
guided prayer map for absolutely free if
you want to learn how to pray salah.
videos on how to pray salah, salah hubs,
and many, many more broken sisters. We
are not an app that shares your
information with third parties. All of
our services on the app is for free.
Download it now. Inshallah. And enjoy,
guys. Let's go back to the video. You're
by a lot, both privately and publicly
are pushing people like you and me away.
Not like we're going to be pro Hamas.
Not like we're going to, but we're like,
honestly, the way you are treating me is
so repulsive. I have text messages,
Megan, calling me an anti-semite. I am
learning biblical Hebrew and writing a
book on the Shabbat. Can you imagine
calling Charlie Kirk a anti-semite? Oh
my god.
It's like they want you to say like this
guy. Charlie Kirk. I despise them. Talk
to me about the Gaza, the children, etc.
Those kids, you know how many thousands
of children are orphans like your own
children now sadly, which is
sad. It's so sad. That's why we don't
want the same for you because it makes
us like you. If I wanted the same to be
done to you, what is the difference
between me and you? Yes. What is the
difference between me and you? Yes. But
look at this. They call you and these
are the one who's like saying, "Yeah,
they're not starving, etc." You know,
justifying the massacre that was going
on there.
Oh boy. Oh boy. I honor the Shabbat,
literally the Jewish Sabbath. I visit
Israel and fight for it. And there's
another article out in the Times of
Israel today. I could read it on air. I
was just reading before I got on.
Charlie, what are you doing? Like, why
are you What am I doing? I'm sorry.
Like, let's just take a step back here.
Like I'm an American citizen. Yes, I
want Israel to win. Yes, I'm a
Christian. But like the sum of the mess
and you saw me, you've seen how I've
been treated, Megan, by some, not all.
By some.
>> No, it's very irritating.
>> It's unfair. They were coming after you
after turning point for among other
things. You had Dave Smith there. Dave
Smith isn't allowed to criticize Israel.
Both sides, the Israeli side, though.
No, you're not allowed to. It's even
worse than that. Again, I just want to
repeat for the fifth time, I love
Israel. I want Israel to win. But
>> do you see how he has to like, you know,
I love Israel. I want it to win, you
know, but that's not enough. It's not
enough. It has to be unconditional
support. No, no, no, no. Unconditional.
>> But my moral character is now being put
into question, Megan. Not my decisions.
Not like, "Hey, are you doing this? Is
it smart or is it dumb?" But no, I am a
bad person if I do this. And it's I
could go I mean, you saw it, Megan. It
was trending on Twitter, thousands of
tweets and text messages. And if I were
to be charitable and generous, I will
say the people that are attacking me are
in a hyper paranoid state because
they're at war. And war tends to make
things black and white. And you're a
hammer looking for a nail. So, I'm
trying to be charitable, Megan.
Literally, I'm trying to cut as much
slack as I can, right? Like, okay, what
would it be like if all of a sudden I'm
starting to see a pattern of behavior
similar to what my grandparents saw in
1930s Germany online? How would I
behave? So, that's like my charitable
kind of over compensation spirit. At the
same time, I'm like, but you're it's
it's not defensible to be dumb, right?
So,
>> and it's offensive. It's offensive to
those of us who have been out there
defending them in in many instances
against critics on our own side. And now
you have a couple of comments like,
well, what about this? Well, has it gone
on too long? Like, is it time to wrap it
up? And the thing about EPC is just so
bizarre. I don't know who he was an
agent for. It might have been Israel or
an asset or it might have been nobody.
But we're allowed to speculate about
that. It's like there's some rule. You
can't go there.
>> There you go. What happened to freedom
of speech? There you go. They are
controlling your government. United
States of Israel. You guys, the world is
waking up to this reality. Even these
hardcore Zistic
>> when it comes to Israel.
>> Well, you and I believe that we're
Americans and Americans first. Period.
End of story. We are citizens of this
nation. Okay? and Israel, we have
funded, we have supported, and they're
up against a sea of Islamic
totalitarianism, and we should be
cheering for them, right? Because
they're up against barbarians and and
monsters, and we want them to win.
However, here is Megan Kelly and Charlie
Kirk combined.
>> Barbarians and monsters. Can can you can
barbarians and monsters? You guys have
massacred most amount of Muslims, and
Muslims are barbarians.
The They're so rich coming. So, we
Muslims are barbarians. You've killed a
million in Iraq, half a million in
Afghanistan, massacring Muslims like
it's happy days,
but we are the barbarians.
Yeah. Okay. Probably 30 million social
media followers. Like pretty, right? And
you and I have been holding this down.
You you probably get the negative, oh,
you're just chilling for Israel. I'm
like, okay, I'm going to do what's right
regardless of the feedback, right? But
then all of a sudden, like I host a
person that I de I moderate the debate
of mine, right? And I give equal time to
Josh Hammer, equal time to a pro-Israel
advocate and my moral character is being
put into question. And so I I just I
think it's a hyper paranoid like we're
>> because they don't want equal. They
don't want you to be equal in order for
them to carry the mask out. You have to
be unjust. If you are saying I've just
hosted two people debate 30 minutes 30
minutes 30 minutes whatever it is.
They're saying no that doesn't work for
us cuz the truth is what that we are
evil. So, we need you to be biased and
don't platform them at all. Do you not
understand?
That's why they say objective news of
what they're doing in genocide. They're
saying that's pro- Hamas. They're saying
objective news is pro Hamas. Guys, you
can't make this crap up, bro. You can't
make it up. And that's why I believe
they killed Charlie Kirk. Msad and
Israel took him out. Yes. This was a
professional hit from that distance 200
yards away. Yes. Okay. What are you
talking about, man? Do you think a a
some college student can do that? Are
you okay? I've look I've been to gun
rangers etc. There was first time in my
life I went to went for a trip etc.
Beautiful. And we had a sniper which
just like just went up brothers just you
know and I was like mate it's bloody
difficult man to hold that hold it. Do
you know how many shots I had to take?
Yes. I'm I'm I'm nearly like half
blindly. Okay. Excuse for me. Yes. Do
you know how many shots I had to take
mate? Like two. Damn difficult. Let me
tell you something. It is difficult. It
is difficult to hold that weapon a
sniper. Yes. And then to align it and it
is difficult. So don't come and tell me
that was done by a professional
somebody who's you know trained IDF.
>> Just going to try to we're going to just
stamp out everything type of practice.
But it goes to the point where if for
example if I I have less ability
sometimes online to criticize the
Israeli government about backlash than
actual is
>> okay. And Harris H. Smith is someone I
think who works with Candace Svin. He
said, "I'm not going to name names, but
I was told by someone close to Charlie
Kirk that Charlie thinks Israel will
kill him if he turns against them." Bro,
you can't make this up, bro. You can't
make this up. Second video. Check this
out, guys. This is my evidence to show
Israel's behind this, which is Okay,
Charlie. We've pushed back against the
media on COVID, on lockdowns, on
Ukraine, on the border, on like maybe we
should also ask a question. Is the media
totally presenting the truth when it
comes to Israel? Just a question, you
know, that maybe we shouldn't believe
everything the media says because I know
I've been conditioned to ask a lot more
critical questions over the last couple
of years. So, Ben, some people would
accuse Israel of wanting to ethnically
cleanse. Did you see did you see Ben Ben
Shapiro's face? He's like this goyum cuz
you're a You're a gentile man. They
don't. Do you think people in Israel
care about Charlie Kirk's death? Except
oh, you supporting them. Let me tell you
something. They spit out Christians.
They spit at you guys. You Christians,
they spit. They spit at you. They curse
your God. They curse the mother of God.
Okay. Yes. They don't care about you, my
friend. You're just a Gentile that's
serving them. Yes. Till their
Antichrist, their Messiah, the
Antichrist comes so they can massacre us
all. Gentiles. Yeah. You know what they
believe about Gentiles. And here's two
more other videos. One with Patrick
David. Let's watch this.
>> I've been in Israel many times. The
whole country is a fortress. When I
first heard this story, I still had the
same gut instinct that I did initially.
I find this very hard to believe. I've
been to that Gaza border. You cannot go
10 feet without running into a
19-year-old with an AR-15 or an
automatic machine gun that is an IDF
soldier, right? The whole country is
surveiled. And so, so let me let me just
kind of go through this. We don't talk
about Israeli politics very often, and
most Americans don't know this. The last
nine months, Israel was on the brink of
civil war. It's not an exaggeration.
This judicial stuff, there were there
were hundreds of thousands of Israelis
taking to the streets because BB
Netanyahu is basically redefining the
Israeli constitution. That's not an
exaggeration, right? He said the
judicial branch is too much power. There
were protests planned this week against
Netanyahu where they anticipated tens of
thousands of people to take to the
streets. That's all gone. Patrick,
Netanyahu now has an emergency
government and a mandate to lead. I'm
not I'm not willing to say to go so far
as saying that Netanyahu knew where
there was intelligence here. But I think
some questions need to be asked. Was
there a standown order?
Was there a standown order? 6 hours. I
don't believe it. Israel's decided to
size New Jersey. When I took a
helicopter ride from Jerusalem to the
Gaza border, it's 45 minutes. Wow. Six
hours. They're live streaming the
killing of Jews. Was did somebody in the
government say stand down? That is a
legitimate non-conspiracy question. The
whole country is the IDF.
>> The whole country is and you're trying
to tell me that they're going to
concerts and kabutzas and schools and by
report
>> that there is another video that cost
him his life. That there guys, look, you
cannot make this up. Here we go. I'll
give you one more video. One more video.
Check this out, guys. Jewish communities
have been pushing the exact kind of
hatred against whites that they claim to
want people to stop using against them.
Now, I don't like generalizations. Not
every Jewish person believes that, but
it is true the Anti-Defamation League
was part and parcel with Black Lives
Matter. It is true that some of the
largest financeers of left-wing
anti-white causes have been
Jewish Americans. They went all in on
woke. And it wasn't just ADL. It was
some of the top Jewish organizations in
the country that have done that. In
fact, we have seen this with the recent
retreat of Jewish donations that are no
longer um going to be administered to
colleges, right? Mark Rowan, Leon
Copperman. Can we get that full list?
Very powerful. The part of the So,
that's totally true. And by the way,
Tucker Carlson reinforces this. So, I'm
going to kind of It was quite a day on
the internet. Tucker Carlson was uh
interviewing Candace Owens. We have
Candace Owens coming up next hour. And
Tucker Carlson mentions that uh Jewish
Americans have primarily been financing
cultural Marxist ideas. We said this, by
the way, last week and people came after
us. We actually said it in a different
way. We said, "I'm glad that Jewish
Americans are reconsidering their
financing of cultural Marxism." And
people misunderstood it intentionally
and slandered us as being anti-semmites.
But listen to this. Tucker Carlson is
completely correct by saying this that
the philosophical foundation
of anti-whitness
has been largely financed by Jewish
donors in the country. Okay. Now guys,
this is obviously it says Charlotte Kirk
figured out. Now like I said before,
this is done by Bazerian. And I'll be
honest with you guys, look, I don't like
this whole thing of um this is done to
us Muslims. Yes, all Jews. I'm so sorry.
I believe this is anti-semitic to come
and say every single Jew. No, so sorry.
Okay, this is a Zionist ideology. Now
there's a lot of Zionists that are
Jewish. Of course, there's a lot of
there was ISIS they were they were
Muslims but they were evil. So we can't
come and say that is Islam. Of course
not. You know and but you can see here
people can see now you need to
understand guys when he is moving like
that and he has a massive following the
young like you saw how Trump was
praising him etc.
But they do not tolerate 1% of
criticism. They see that as if today you
can question me on this, tomorrow you're
going to question me on something else.
So these videos show you what a pattern
of where Charlie Kirk was going. And
they took him out. They assassinated
him. And that sniper was a professional
sniper to listen my friend to get that
hit from 200 yard distance when there is
a tent above his head which is difficult
to see from an angle.
from a rooftop. You've got a tent which
can get in the way of seeing. And then
you've got two individuals. By the way,
there was a video I'll show you as well
of two individuals with security guard.
The way he fixed his hat, the way No,
that that didn't look like he was fixing
his hat. That genuinely looked like a
go-ahad to this like they were working
with someone up the roof. You can see it
close. I can show it to you as well.
That was like a sight that take the hit
and and and it's just all crazy and
stuff that he said Charlie is going to
be remembered for the Gaza genocide that
he supported you know and the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him told us and
it's very ironic because people say that
you know you've got ignorance like Tommy
Robertson and absolute flipping
intellectual midgets come back yeah
saying that Islam Islam is anti-semitic
antiism comes from crusaders my friend
with all due respect yeah but where
Jewish funeral was walking past the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him if we
had hostility towards the Jewish people
etc which is an answer that comes from
the Christian crusade is not from us. He
got up and the prophet and one of his
companions said of Allah it's a Jewish
man. He said was he not a human? Was he
not a human? He paid his respects by
standing. Yes, that's it. We don't this
his affair Charlie Clark's affair is now
with God Almighty. We believe from our
belief system he is going that he died
on disbelief. He was supporting a
genocide. We don't believe a God that is
the almighty that's the most merciful
the most just is going to send someone
like that to heaven with all due respect
but neither we are going to you know his
affairs with God almighty good or bad
the matter's close that's all I have to
say inshallah and I believe this brings
enough evidence to show that Mossad and
Benjamin Netanyahu was behind the
assassination of Charlie and the whole
world can see that till next
We better catch.